matthias welche details sind denn über
diese besondere beziehung der beiden
heute ans licht gekommen
es soll ja über eine generalvollmacht
sind gesprochen worden sein dort frau
gerächt ja also genauer gesagt hat
bushido durch die ordnung der
steuerfahndung die seine bücher
beschlagnahmt hatte erst mal mitbekommen
dass es überhaupt zwei general verträge
gab von denen er gar nichts wusste
bushido hat erzählt dass diese
generalvollmacht wie er mit arafat abou
chaker geschlossen hat einen
zusatzvertrag beinhaltet und zwar den
hat arafat mit sich selbst geschlossen
inhalt pikant selbst beim plötzlichen
tod des paten hätten hätten seine erben
seine kinder weiter an bushido elf
verdient also das ist wie ein parasit
der sich am körper im körper von seinem
opfer selbst weiter annähern matthias
jetzt ist bushido nicht der einzige
hochkarätige zeuge dort in diesem
prozess gegen den clan chef ging das
clan mitglied sind
wer steht noch so hochkarätiges auf der
zeugenliste die zeugenliste ich bekannt
also am mittwoch wird erwartet die
ehefrau von bushido das ist anna-maria
sie auch sie wird deutliche worte ist
wahrscheinlich finden im verhältnis zu
arafat abou chaker der sie mehr als
drangsaliert teilweise wohl auch sehr
rüde mit ihr umgegangen ist
auf der zeugenliste stehen richter es
steht der psychologe von bushido er wird
erzählen welche auswirkungen die psyche
von bushido genommen hat auf druck des
kleinbusses
erstaunlich ist auch der rechtsanwalt
den bushido und anna fantl sich geteilt
haben
er ist der vorsitzende der berliner
strafverteidiger
auch er ist auf der liste der zeugen die
wenn bushido ihnen was zu erwarten ist
von seiner schweigeverpflichtung
entbindet wird er geladen und das hat
natürlich eine brisanz
in einem gespräch in einem vertraulichen
gespräch mit seinem rechtsanwalt werden
natürlich alle details genannt auch
details genannt
die vielleicht strafrechtlich sind aber
nie bekannt oben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bild schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren